ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY NOTICES THE
OP ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA.
AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO.
CALDERON CARILLO SURVIVED HAS
CHAU CHAVEZ
CHEN. DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER. CUNNINGHAM.
SALLY.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
LARA.
FONG
FREED MEN.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA. GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER.
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE. LIMON OWN.
LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES.
CARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MYRRH ITCHY NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER. WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE STATE'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND BOB OSHITA. REVENUE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
I REMEMBER WELL A CONVERSATION I
HAD WITH MY WIFE OVER THREE
DECADES AGO.
THIS HAPPENED WITHIN THE FIRST
YEAR OF OUR MARRIAGE.
I WAS TAKEN ABACK WHEN PATTY
SAID TO ME ONE EVENING YOU KNOW.
YOU'RE MET MUCH BETTER MINISTER
THEN YOUR HUSBAND.
I AM ACQUIRED Y. AND SHE
EXPLAINED. WHEN YOU'RE AT THE
OFFICE AND PEOPLE COME TO TALK
WITH YOU. YOUR PATIENT
INATTENTIVE. YOU LISTEN
CAREFULLY AND YOU RESPOND
THOUGHTFULLY.
AT HOME I SOMETIMES WONDER IF
YOU CAN HEAR WHAT I'M SHARING
WITH YOU.
I KNEW IMMEDIATELY SHE WAS
RIGHT.
I APOLOGIZED AND AGREED THAT SHE
WAS RIGHT. BUT IN WEEK DEFENSE I
TRUTHFULLY ADDED YOU KNOW. I'VE
BEEN A MINISTER A LOT LONGER
THAN I'VE BEEN A HUSBAND.
I'VE BEEN A MINISTER FOR ELEVEN
YEARS AND A HUSBAND FOR ONLY A
FEW MONTHS.
SO IF YOU GIVE ME A LITTLE MORE
TIME. I KNOW I CAN BE A BETTER
HUSBAND.
I SMILED AND ADDED IF EVER YOU
REALLY NEED TO TALK TO ME JUST
COME BY THE OFFICE.
FORTUNATELY SHE ONLY ROLLED HER
EYES.
ALTHOUGH DECADES HAVE PASSED.
THAT CONVERSATION HAS NEVER LEFT
ME.
IT REMAINED A REMINDER.
THAT THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM FOR
MUCH IMPROVEMENT IN EVERY ASPECT
OF MY LIFE.
AS WE NEED MOVE FORWARD INTO THE
SECOND MONTH AT THE NEW YEAR.
LET US ALL TRY TO BE THE BEST
HUMAN BEINGS WE CAN BE. IN EVERY
DIMENSION OF OUR LIVES.
WITH HONESTY AND HUMILITY WILL
BECOME OPEN AND EVEN GRATEFUL
FOR CARING ENCOURAGEMENT.
BECOME THE BEST PEOPLE WE
POSSIBLY CAN BE.
THERE IS ALWAYS. FOR
IMPROVEMENT.
NUMBER ONE.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU EVER KNOW SO WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE. JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY AS HE LEADS US IN
OUR NATION'S PLEDGE.
SAREK.
BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JAN.
WE MET AND I.
ON WILL AMP MISTER CALDERON
MOVES AND MISTER BONTA SECONDS
pDAY'S JOURNAL WILL BE DISPENSED
WITH.
PRESENTATION OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTIONS AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS LIKE.
BLOOM HOLDEN MAYES AND.
WE GOT OF GERMAN.
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS THIS MORNING WILL KNOW A
ABSENCES OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER AL
MURATSUCHI FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ROCKY CHAVEZ AND
MIGUEL SANTIAGO FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN FOR
PATERNITY LEAVE
OUR MEMBERS WE WILL THE DAILY
FILE. ITEMS ONE
THROUGH FOR OUR CONTINUED.
THAT BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY SIX BY FAMILY MEMBERS
AMOUNT RELATIVE TO AMERICAN
HEART MONTH AND WEAR RED DAY.
THERE'S I ASK YOU TO GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALONE FOR REPRESENTATION MS
AMONG.
AND THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
THE AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION.
AND THE AMERICAN STROKE
ASSOCIATION IS PROUD TO SPONSOR
ACR ONE FOUR SIX WHICH
RECOGNIZES FEBRUARY AS HEART
MONTH AND TODAY AS WEAR RED DAY
IN THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
THIS ANNUAL EVENT IS CRUCIAL TO
WEARING IT TO RAISING AWARENESS
AGAINST THE FIGHTS
AS FOR CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE.
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE ACCOUNTS
FOR NEARLY A HUNDRED AND ONE.
THOU A HUNDRED AND EIGHT.
A HUNDRED EIGHT HUNDRED AND ONE
THOUSAND THERE WE GO DEATHS IN
THE U. S. THAT'S ABOUT ONE IN
EVERY THREE DEATHS IN THE U. S.
AN AVERAGE OF ONE DEATH. FOR
EVERY FORTY SECONDS.
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASES CLAIM
MORE LIVES EACH YEAR THAN ALL
FORMS OF CANCER AND CHRONIC
LOWER RESPIRATORY DISEASE
COMBINED.
IN PARTICULAR HEART DISEASE IS
THE NUMBER ONE KILLER OF WOMEN.
AS AT AN ESTIMATED FORTY FOUR
MILLION WOMEN IN THE UNITED
STATES ARE AFFECTED BY
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASES.
NINETY PERCENT OF WOMEN HAVE ONE
OR MORE RISK FACTORS FOR HEART
DISEASE OR STROKE.
EIGHTY PERCENT OF CARDIOVASCULAR
EVENTS MAY BE PREVENTED BY
LIFESTYLE CHANGES AND EDUCATION.
THE AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
GO RED FOR WOMEN MOVEMENT.
ADVOCATES FOR MORE RESEARCH AND
SISTER ACTION FOR WOMEN'S HEART
HEALTH.
YOU CAN DO SO BY FOLLOWING LIFE
SIMPLE SEVEN.
ONE ENGAGING IN DAILY PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY. TO MAINTAIN A HEALTHY
DIET.
THREE KEEPING A HEALTHY WAY.
FOR CONTROLLING CHOLESTEROL FIVE
MANAGING BLOOD PRESSURE SIX
REDUCING BLOOD SUGAR LEVELS AND
SEVEN REFRAINING FROM SMOKING OR
USING TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
WOMEN WHO ARE INVOLVED WITH THE
GO RED FOR WOMEN MOVEMENT LIVE
HEALTHIER LIVES.
SO LET'S CONTINUE THIS AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN TO ENSURE WOMEN
EVERYWHERE CAN LIVE STRONGER
HEALTHIER LIVES I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FORTY SIX AND
I ALSO ASK THAT ALL OF THOSE OF
YOU WHO HAVE JOINED MEAN WEARING
RED. AT THE END OF THIS
PRESENTATION MEET ME IN THE BACK
FOR A PICTURE.
THANK YOU MS MALONE SEEN OTHER A
REQUEST FOR TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM I'VE MISSED AMOUNT IS
ASKING FOR CO AUTHORS ON THIS.
RESOLUTION.
WELL OPEN THE ROLE FOR THAT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
HELLO COULDN'T HOLD ON THE CO
AUTHORS FOR THIS RESOLUTION
.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THOUGH
SIXTY THREE CO AUTHORS ON THAT
RESOLUTION THINKING ASTHMA.
IN.
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS LIMON YOU
HAVE SOME VISITORS.
THANK YOU AND MISTER SPEAKER
TODAY I'D LIKE TO WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS HAD.
LINDSEY DIRE AND JESSICA GORDON
LANNON AS WELL AS STAFF OF THE
AMERICAN HEART AND STROKE
ASSOCIATION IN THE GALLERY.
SO DO YOU THINK THAT.
THE BOARD.
I MEAN ANY HAD.
LINDSEY'S IS EVERYTHING HAD
CARDIAC ARREST SURVIVOR WHO WAS
SAVED BY BYSTANDERS PERFORMING
HANDS ONLY CPR.
HE COLLAPSED DURING A LUNCH TIME
RUN
SINCE HER CARDIAC ARRESTS
AND THE FOLLOW IN FOLLOWING HER
RECOVERY LEAVE LINDSAY HAS
DEDICATED HERSELF TO RAISE
AWARENESS FOR HEART DISEASE.
SHE ALSO STRESSES THE IMPORTANCE
OF KNOWING HANDS ONLY CPR
BECAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW WHEN THEY
CAN SAVE LIVES.
SACRAMENTO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
JESSICA GORDON LAND.
HAS BEEN PART OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION FOR OVER TEN YEARS
PERMISSION
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR IS TO BUILD
HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES THROUGH
POWERFUL PARTNERSHIPS THROUGHOUT
THE GREATER SACRAMENTO REGION.
PLEASE GIVE THEM A WARM WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISS LIMON WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
MEMBERS IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY BY
SAYING I.
ANY OPPOSED.
THAT PASSES UNANIMOUSLY CAN.
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY AND ITEM
NUMBER SIX WILL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SIXTY BY SOME A MEMBER BAKER
BELTED TO PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGIST WEEK.
MEMBERS ASKING GIVE MS BAKER
YOUR ATTENTION THIS BAKER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
PRESENT YOU TODAY ACR ONE SIXTY.
TODAY AND ALL THIS WEEK WE ARE
COMMEMORATING FROM JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH THROUGH FEBRUARY
THIRD PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS WEEK.
ANNUALLY MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
MILLION OPERATIONS AND
PROCEDURES ARE PERFORMED WITH
ANESTHESIA IN THE UNITED STATES
AND PHYSICIAN ANESTHESIOLOGISTS
ARE LEADERS IN PROMOTING PATIENT
SAFETY. AND THE PHYSICIANS WHO
EVALUATE PATIENT PRIOR TO
PROCEDURES.
THEY ALSO ADMINISTER ANESTHESIA
DURING SURGERY AND MONITOR THE
PATIENT'S CONDITION AND ASSESS
THE PATIENT'S AFTER PROCEDURE IS
COMPLETED.
PHYSICIAN ANESTHESIOLOGISTS HAVE
BETWEEN TWELVE THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN THOUSAND HOURS OF
TRAINING WHICH HELPS THEM TO
MINIMIZE RISKS MONITOR FOR ANY
PROBLEMS AND TAKE QUICK ACTION
TO SAVE LIVES AND PROMOTE
PATIENT WELL BEING. PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS HAVE BEEN
RECOGNIZED AND CLINICAL PEER
REVIEW JOURNALS FOR REDUCING
MEDICAL ERRORS IN THE UNITED
STATES WITH A TWENTY PERCENT
REDUCTION IN ADVERSE EVENTS WHEN
THE PHYSICIAN ANESTHESIOLOGISTS
LEADS THE ANESTHESIA CARE TEAM
DURING THE PROCEDURE.
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS ARE EXPERTS IN
PAIN MANAGEMENT AND THEY HAVE
BEEN PROACTIVE IN CURBING THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC IN FACT THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS HAS BEEN AT
THE FOREFRONT IN HELPING
PHYSICIANS. BETTER COMMUNICATE
WITH PATIENTS UNDERGOING
SURGERIES SO THEY CAN AVOID
OPIATES AND TOO MUCH PAIN CARE.
THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO
MAINTAINING PATIENT LIFE AND
GOOD OUTCOMES.
AND ON A PERSONAL LEVEL.
WHEN I AYE I WANTED TO BRING
THIS PARTICULAR RESOLUTION
BECAUSE.
OF IT IMPACTED AN
ANESTHESIOLOGIST HAD ON ME WHEN
I WAS TWENTY ONE.
MISTER SPEAKER CAN WE HAVE
SUPPORT ON THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS ASK YOU TO GIVE MS BAKER
YOUR ATTENTION PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS AND.
WAS BIGGER PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU JUST.
QUICKLY WHEN I WAS TWENTY ONE.
I WAS GOING INTO SURGERY TO
REMOVE A MALIGNANT TUMOR FROM MY
NECK.
AND IT WAS THE ANESTHESIOLOGIST
WHO CAME IN DURING PRE OP AND
SHOWED THE MOST CARE THE MOST
KINDNESS AND MADE IT VERY CLEAR
TO ME THAT HE WAS GOING TO BE
THERE TO MAKE SURE MY HEART KEPT
GOING. MY LUNGS KEPT BREATHING
AND I WOULD COME OUT OKAY.
AND I STILL HAVE THE SCAR FROM
THE.
NEEDLE THAT THEY HAD TO
INTRODUCE WHEN I SEE IT I DON'T
THINK OF BAD THINGS I DO
REMEMBER THAT ANESTHESIOLOGIST
EVERY SINGLE TIME FOR THE CARE.
AND.
COMFORT THAT HE SHARED AT THAT
PARTICULAR TIME AND
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS ARE THE ONES
YOU WANT IN THE ROOM. WHEN THERE
IS SOMETHING GOING WRONG MY
FATHER IN LAW IS AN
ANESTHESIOLOGIST HE JUST RETIRED
AFTER FIFTY FOUR YEARS OF
PRACTICE.
AND HAS SHARED TALES WITH ME
ABOUT WHEN HE'S BEEN A DIFFERENT
EVENTS AND FOLKS WAS ASKED FOR A
DOCTOR IN THE ROOM.
AND SOMETIMES A DOCTOR COMES BUT
THEN WHEN THEY FIND OUT MY
FATHER IN LAW ANESTHESIOLOGIST
IS THERE THEY SAY THIS IS THE
ONE YOU WANT.
SO I'M I'M PROUD TO A SPONSORED
THIS I KNOW THAT WHEN MUCH TWIN
CHILDREN WERE BORN IT WAS THE
ANESTHESIOLOGIST WHO MADE SURE
BEFOREHAND I WAS IN GOOD SHAPE
AND WE HAVE. A A GOOD CAREER IN
ANESTHESIOLOGIST I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND HAPPY TO
OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS IF
I'M ALLOWED TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS BAKER.
DOCTOR CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I RISE SO IN THE STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS OUR ACR ONE HER SIXTY. I
SHOULD'VE BEEN THE OUR AUTHOR.
OF BEFORE ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAKER
TOOK UP ON ON THAT.
A PERSONALLY I. ON MY SINUS AYE
AND THE FEES HISTOLOGIST SO WHY
CAN I HAVE. A TWO.
YEAH I SUPPORT THE ASSAULT ONE
THE FOUR LAW OUR MANAGER.
AS I OBSERVE HIM HOW.
DIFFICULT JOB HE DOES SO IS SO
EVERY DAY THE STORIES AFTER A
SOURCE OF THAT I HEAR. AND THE
THINK ABOUT IT ANY SURGERY
WITHOUT THE AND IF YOU SEE ALL
THAT YOU. WILL COME UP PAID
ENOUGH PEOPLE WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH. AND THIS ON THE ONE
SIDE. TO MAKE YOU FEEL SO
COMFORTABLE. AND US SUSAN SECOND
OPERATE ON. SO I THINK WE SHOULD
THE RECOGNIZE AND THAT THIS OUT
ACR ONE SIXTY AS SAU PROPER
THING LOW FOR US TO OUR SUPPORT
AGAIN NEXT YEAR THANK YOU ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND MS BAKER I BELIEVE YOU'RE
ASKING FOR CO AUTHORS ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS BECAUSE ON HIS
MAKERS RESOLUTION.
QUICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
ARE SIXTY FIVE CO AUTHORS.
MISS BAKER YOU HAVE SOME
VISITORS EUROPE. ONCE.
BEFORE WE RECOGNIZE YOUR
VISITORS ASK FOR AN AYE AYE
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL HAVE AN
AYE AYE VOICE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION ALL'S MEMBERS.
WISHING TO VOTE I'VE VS PLEADING
FOR WISHING TO VOTE IN THE
AFFIRMATIVE PLEASE SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE AYE. ANY OPPOSED.
THAT PASSES UNANIMOUSLY THIS
BAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR VISITORS YES VERY PLEASE TO
HAVE.
FROM THE PROOF OF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS AND ASSOCIATE
CLINICAL PROFESSOR AT UCLA
HEALTH CARE AND DOCTOR KAREN
CYBER. AND ALSO DOCTOR JEFF POKE
CHAIRED THE LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
OF CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS A MEDICAL
DIRECTOR AT CHILDREN MEMBERS
WERE WORKING BACK OF A
BACK UP ON THE FILE TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FIFTY NINE BY SOME THE
MEMBER TING RELATIVE TO FRED
KOREMATSU DAY OF CIVIL LIBERTIES
AND THE CONSTITUTION.
RESEARCHING YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
VERY PROUD TO RISE TODAY IS VICE
CHAIR OF THE. EP I LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS
PRESENT ACR ONE FIFTY NINE. A
ACR ONE FIFTY NINE RECOGNIZES
JANUARY THIRTIETH AS FRED
KOREMATSU DAY.
FRED KOREMATSU. IS.
A.
OR IT WAS AN ORDINARY AMERICAN.
WHO SHOWN GREAT COURAGE AND
RESOLVE IN THE FACE OF
ADVERSITY?
HE JOINS A LONG LINE OF ORDINARY
AMERICANS WHO HAVE STOOD UP.
TO FIGHT FOR HIS CIVIL RIGHTS IN
THE EYES OF INJUSTICE AND
INEQUALITY.
HE AT THE TIME. WAS THE ORDINARY
AMERICAN LIVING IN THE BAY AREA.
JAPANESE AMERICAN DESCENT
WHERE AFTER THE BOMBING OF PEARL
HARBOR WE PASSED THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER NINE OH SIX SIX.
IT REALLY BECAUSE OF THAT
EXECUTIVE ORDER WHICH WAS
PASSED.
JAPANESE AMERICANS WERE UNJUSTLY
BEEN AN AND A COMPLETE A CAR
SERRATED ACROSS THE WEST COAST
AND PUT.
INTO CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
AROUND THE UNITED STATES.
PER CORE MATSUE DECIDED THAT HE
WANTED TO I STAY IN THE BAY AREA
HE AT THAT POINT WAS.
DATING SOMEBODY IN THE BAY AREA
WANTED TO JUST BE.
NEAR HIS GIRLFRIEND
SO HE THE FIVE AND THAT
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT HE WAS PUT
IN JAIL.
IN HIS CASE NOW WAS LITIGATED
IN.
TAKEN UP BY THEY STILL YOU AND
TAKEN UP ALL THE WAY TO THE U.
S. SUPREME COURT.
IT IS NOW BECOME ONE OF THE MOST
FAMOUS A US SUPREME COURT CASES.
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY IS IN
THAT EVERY SINGLE LAW STUDENT
STUDIES.
DURING CONSTITUTIONAL LAW.
SO I'M AGAIN VERY VERY PROUD TO
RISE TODAY TO RECOGNIZE.
JANUARY THIRTIETH THIS AYE FRED
KOREMATSU DAY AND URGED THE
ASSEMBLY TO PASS A.
THANK YOU MISTER KING MR MCCARTY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FIFTY
NINE. FRED COURT KOREMATSU HIS
STORY IS THAT OF A PHOENIX
RISING FROM THE ASHES OF FEAR
AND INJUSTICE ON WHAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN HIS. NINETY NINTH BIRTHDAY
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
pSERVES A REMINDER TO ALL OF US
AS A CALL TO ACTION. IN DEFENSE
OF THE RIGHTS OF OTHERS
UNFORTUNATE UNFORTUNATE TODAY WE
HAVE SOMBER REMINDERS OF THE
POLITICS OF DIVISIVENESS. AND
THIS HAS CERTAINLY SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES
IF NECESSARY THAT WEEK
CONTINUALLY RISE UNITED BECAUSE
THE FIGHT FOR CIVIL JUSTICE IS
JUST AS RELEVANT THEN AS IT IS
TODAY.
MISTER KOREMATSU DEDICATE THE
REST OF HIS LIFE.
THE FIGHT FOR JUSTICE AND THIS
IS WHY WE CELEBRATE HIS LEGACY
TODAY AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
OUR VOTE ON ACR ONE FIFTY NINE.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY.
SEEN OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED KING WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AGAIN I I HAD THE VERY DISTINCT
HONOR.
PREVIOUS TO JOIN THE ASSEMBLY
TO BE THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE ASIAN LAW CAUCUS IS AN
ORGANIZATION. THAT WORKED.
THIRTY YEARS AFTER THAT CASE
HAPPENED TO HELP OVERTURN OF
FRANCE CONVICTION AND OUTSIDE
THE DISTINCT HONOR TO WORK WITH
HIS DAUGHTER CARA KOREMATSU WHO
WAS ON MY BOARD AT THAT TIME. IS
SO THIS IS.
IT PERSON WHO AGAIN WAS OUR
ORDINARY AMERICAN WHO REALLY
STOOD UP.
FOR OUR CIVIL RIGHTS AND RELIEF
FOR ALL OF US DURING THE TIME
THAT WAS A VERY TENSE AND VERY
XENOPHOBIC.
WITHOUT I REQUEST THAT THE
ASSEMBLY I RECOGNIZE JANUARY
THIRTIETH THAT'S FRED KOREMATSU
DAY THANK YOU.
THEY CAN ASKING YOUR QUESTION CO
AUTHORS ON THIS RESOLUTION.
VERY GOOD SEE NO FOR THE DEBATE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR
CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO BE
ADDED AS CO AUTHORS
.
ON THE VERGE VOTE EXACT EVENT.
CLICK A CLOSE CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS
WITHOUT OBJECTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MERGE MASUCCI WILL BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. WILL NOW
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
PLEASE SAY AYE.
ANY OPPOSED.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
OUR MEMBERS WERE CONTINUE
THROUGH THE FILE WERE MOVING TO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY THREE
BY SIGH MEMBER REYES AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO ROSA PARKS A HUNDRED
FIFTH BIRTHDAY.
MS REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU HR
SEVENTY THREE. WHICH HONORS WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN ROSA PARKS ONE
HUNDRED FIFTH BIRTHDAY.
AND I URGE ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
REMEMBER THIS GREAT WOMAN.
ROSA PARKS ONCE SAID YOU MUST
NEVER BE FEARFUL ABOUT WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
WHEN IT IS RIGHT.
WE REMEMBER THE SHE REFUSE TO
GIVE UP HER SEAT.
SO WHAT MEN WHEN SHE WAS ASKED
BY THE BUS DRIVER.
WE REMEMBER THAT SHE WAS
ARRESTED WE REMEMBER THAT SHE
FOUGHT THE CASE TO THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT AND WE KNOW THAT
SHE ULTIMATELY ONE.
ROSA PARKS IS BORN ON FEBRUARY
FOURTH NINETEEN THIRTEEN IN
TUSKEGEE ALABAMA.
THE FIRST CHILD OF JAMES AND
LEONA MCCAULEY.
REVERED AS THE CIVIL RIGHTS ICON
ROSA PARKS IS BEST KNOWN. FOR
THAT FOR SPARKING THE NINETEEN
FIFTY FIVE MONTGOMERY BUS
BOYCOTT.
BUT YOU'RE ACTIVISM IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY PRE DATES THAT DAY.
SHE JOINED THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION FOR THE ADVANCEMENT
OF COLORED PEOPLE NAACP. IN
NINETEEN FOURTY THREE. TWELVE
YEARS BEFORE THAT FATEFUL
COMMUTE.
SOME LESSER KNOWN FACTS.
ABOUT ROSA PARKS.
IS WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE.
IN HER FIRST YEARS IN THE
ORGANIZATION SHE WORKS
SPECIFICALLY ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE
ISSUES. IN ALABAMA COMMUNITIES.
ROSA PARKS WAS HONORED AS THE
MOTHER OF THE MODERN DAY CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT
BECAUSE HER DELIBERATE ACTS OF
DEFIANCE BEGAN A MOVEMENT THAT
ENDED LEGAL SEGREGATION. IN OUR
COUNTRY AND MADE HER AN
INSPIRATION TO FREEDOM LOVING
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
WELL WE HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY
GRAPPLE WITH ISSUES OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND SEXUAL ASSAULT.
IS IS.
LOOK AT IT NATIONWIDE.
MANY DO NOT KNOW THAT ROSA PARKS
WHILE WORKING FOR THE NAACP WAS
A KEY FIGURE IN EFFORTS TO
PROTECT. AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN
WHO ARE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
SHE ALSO FOUGHT TO PROTECT
AFRICAN AMERICAN MAN FROM FALSE
ACCUSATIONS AND LYNCHINGS.
SURE WORK TO ENSURE THAT AFRICAN
AMERICANS WHO HAD BEEN SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED COULD SEEK JUSTICE.
THE END DOUBLE ACP APPOINTED HER
TO INVESTIGATE THE ASSAULT OF RE
SEE TAYLOR.
ON SUNDAY SEPTEMBER THIRD
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR. TWENTY FOUR
YEAR OLD RE SEE TAYLOR WAS
WALKING HOME FROM CHURCH WITH
HER FRIEND FANNIE DANIEL.
SHE WAS KIDNAPPED AND RAPED BY A
GROUP OF WHITE MEN.
WHEN THE NEWS REACHED MONTGOMERY
OFFICES OF THE N. DOUBLE A. C.
P.. THEY RESPONDED BY SENDING AN
INVESTIGATOR.
HER NAME ROSA PARKS.
ROSA PARKS' MADE HER WAY TO THE
TAILOR HOME ONLY TO FIND THE
SHERIFF WAITING FOR HER. WHO
DEMANDED THAT SHE LEAVE?
PARKS WAS UNDETERRED RETURNED TO
MONTGOMERY WHERE SHE PROMPTLY
LAUNCHED THE COMMITTEE FOR EQUAL
JUSTICE FOR THE RIGHTS OF MRS
RECEIVED TAYLOR.
ROSA PARKS IN RECENT TAYLOR
FOUGHT TO HOLD THE PERPETRATORS
OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
ACCOUNTABLE SOME SIXTY YEARS
BEFORE OUR CURRENT EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
ROSA PARKS LIVE THE LIFE THAT
WAS LONG AND INSPIRATIONAL WELL
BEYOND OF THE SINGLE ACT
OVER HUSING TO GIVE UP HER SEAT.
TO A SYSTEM UP AND OF INJUSTICE
AND OPPRESSION.
SHE IS LEFT AN IMPACT NOT JUST
ON THE NATION BOMB THE WORLD.
ROSA PARKS DEDICATED HER LIFE TO
THE CAUSE OF HUMAN RIGHTS
AND TRULY EMBODIED THE LOVE OF
JUSTICE AND FREEDOM.
FINALLY I'D LIKE TO SHARE THAT
TOMORROW IN SAN BERNADINO.
WE HAVE OUR OWN PERSONAL
CELEBRATION OF ROSA PARKS.
THANKS TO ASSISTANCE FROM OUR
SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON AND OUR.
BUDGET CHAIR PHIL TEEING.
SANDRA DINO WILL CELEBRATE THE
UNVEILING OF THE ROSA PARKS
STATUE. AT THE ROSA PARKS STATE
MEMORIAL.
BUILDING.
I HOPE THAT SOME OF YOU WILL
JOIN US FOR THIS HISTORIC EVENT.
I AM PROUD THAT SOME OF ROSA
PARKS FAMILY WILL ALSO BE IN
ATTENDANCE.
SO TODAY PLEASE JOIN ME IN
HONORING WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
THE ONE HUNDRED FIFTH BIRTHDAY
OF ROSA PARKS.
AND LET'S REMEMBER HER FOR HER
COURAGE
AND HER CONTRIBUTION TO THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE FIRST.
ROLL BE OPENED FOR CO AUTHORS
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK HIM ISRAEL'S.
STIR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AS CHAIR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR
SEVENTY THREE AND I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD.
TO THIS DAY ROSA PARKS LEGACY.
SERVES
AS AN INSURANCE SYMBOL OF LOVE.
AND OF JUSTICE.
WHEN SHE REMAINED IN HER SEAT
ON THAT BUS IN MONTGOMERY ON
DECEMBER FIRST NINETEEN FIFTY
FIVE HER ACTION.
BECAME A CATALYST FOR CHANGE.
A SINGLE PEBBLE.
IN THE WATER WHOSE RIPPLE TURNED
INTO A WAVE OF CHANGE AND
ACTIVISM FOR MORE THAN FORTY
THOUSAND BLACK. MEGAMI RESIDENTS
WHO FOLLOWED HER LEADERSHIP AND
BOYCOTTED THE BUSES IN
MONTGOMERY UNTIL THE SUPREME
COURT OF THE UNITED STATES
RULED.
THAT MONTGOMERY'S SEGREGATION
LAWS WERE UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THIS WITH EITHER THE BEGINNING
OR THE END OF MRS PARKS
ACTIVISM.
HER LIFE WAS DEDICATED TO
STANDING HER GROUND AND SPEAKING
UP.
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS AND FOR
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL JUSTICE.
SHE WAS A LIFELONG ACTIVIST AND
FAMOUSLY SAID THE ONLY TIRED I
WAS.
WAS TIRED OF GIVING IN.
THESE WORDS STILL RESONATE AND
CONTINUE. TO INSPIRE US TODAY WE
MUST RECOGNIZE THE INEQUITIES
THAT CONTINUE TO EXIST IN OUR
SOCIETY. AND BE RELENTLESS IN
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND PROVIDING ALL PEOPLE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REALIZE THEIR
DREAMS AND ACHIEVE THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL.
AGAIN I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD
SO THAT WE MAY REFLECT ON THE
LEGACY OF ROSA PARKS AND HONOR
HER ON WHAT WOULD BE. HER
HUNDRED FIFTH BIRTHDAY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AYE VOTE
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA DOCTOR
WHETHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY
I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR SEVENTY
THREE WHICH HONORS A HUNDRED
FIFTH BIRTHDAY OF ROSA PARKS.
AND URGES ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
REMEMBER THIS GREAT AMERICAN
WOMAN.
THIS YOUR BLACK PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY OBVIOUSLY IS RATHER
UNIQUE AND VIBRANT.
AND IT IS ONLY APPROPRIATE THAT
WE BEGIN BLACK HISTORY MONTH
WITH THE CELEBRATION OF ONE OF
ITS MOST SIGNIFICANT ICONS ROSA
PARKS.
THERE'S VERY LITTLE I CAN TELL
YOU ABOUT ALL THE PARTS THAT YOU
DON'T ALREADY KNOW.
BECAUSE A STORY IS TOLD OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT SHE WAS A
WOMAN OF TREMENDOUS COURAGE AND
STRENGTH.
WE ALL KNOW THAT SHE REALLY
WASN'T PHYSICALLY TIRED ANY MORE
THAN SHE HAD BEEN BEFORE.
SHE WAS JUST TIRED OF BEING
TREATED THE WAY SHE WAS TREATED
IN THIS COUNTRY.
SHE WAS SICK AND TIRED OF BEING
SICK AND TIRED.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT SHE MODE
IT MOTIVATED HER TO ONCE AGAIN
STAND AND TO STAND FOR WHAT WAS
RIGHT AND WHAT WAS JUST.
BUT WHAT I TEACH HISTORY TO MY
STUDENTS I TRY TO HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND MORE THAN JUST THE
FACTUAL INFORMATION THAT THEY
SEE.
BUT HOPEFULLY THE GOING FROM ITS
SOMETHING THAT REALLY SHOULD
MOTIVATE THEM TO BE A PART OF
HISTORY THEMSELVES AND TO MAKE
HISTORY IN THEIR LIVES.
YOU KNOW WHEN I THINK OF ROSA
PARKS.
I OFTEN TALK ABOUT THE POWER OF
ONE PERSON.
THE POWER OF AN INDIVIDUAL TO
BRING CHANGE IN THE MIDST OF ALL
OF THE THINGS THAT PEOPLE ARE
FACED WITH.
AND ONE LITTLE AFRICAN AMERICAN
HISTORY YOU THINK ABOUT THE KIND
OF CHALLENGE THAT AFRICAN
AMERICANS HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
TO OVERTURN SLAVERY.
THE FIGHT FOR JUSTICE AND
EQUALITY AGAINST THE MOST
POWERFUL FORCE IN THE WORLD.
AND TO BE JUST SMALL INDIVIDUALS
WHO DO THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
POWERFUL THEY DON'T COME FROM
POWERFUL COUNTRIES THAT CAN COME
IN AND DEFEND THEIR IDENTITY AND
WHO THEY ARE.
AND YET THAT INTERNAL. AND AN
INTERNAL PERSEVERANCE IS WHAT
DRIVES IN EACH AND EVERY DAY.
TO BE A PART OF THIS COUNTRY TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND TO DEMAND
THAT THEY BE RESPECTED.
YOU KNOW I THINK OF ROSA PARKS
SHE IS NOT THE FIRST TO SET ON
THE BUS AND OFTENTIMES YOU HEAR
HISTORIANS TALK ABOUT ALL THE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO FOUGHT
AGAINST THAT SYSTEM.
THOSE WHO REFUSED TO GET UP ON
THE BUS ALSO REFUSED TO MOVE AND
THEY WERE PULLED OFF THE BUS
BEATEN DRAG SOMETIMES LYNCHED AS
EXAMPLES OF WHAT YOU SHOULD NOT
DO.
AND YOU THINK ABOUT THAT AND YOU
SAY TO SELL ALL. SO SHE WASN'T
THE FIRST NO SHE WASN'T BUT
THEY'RE STILL COURAGE IN IT
BECAUSE THINK ABOUT IT.
IF YOU HAD SEEN WHAT THE RESULTS
OF YOUR ACTIONS WOULD BE.
YOU'D BE LESS LIKELY WILLING TO
TAKE THOSE ACTIONS.
IT WASN'T THAT SHE DID KNOW THAT
SHE WAS GOING TO BE ARRESTED SHE
HAD NO IDEA WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO
HER SHE KNEW WHAT IT HAPPEN TO
OTHERS.
AND YET DESPITE THAT BECAUSE IT
WAS RIGHT BECAUSE IT WAS JUST
BECAUSE IT WAS HER TIME.
SHE DECIDED TO DO THAT ANYWAY.
AND THAT MAKES IT EVEN MORE
COURAGEOUS.
BECAUSE SHE KNEW WHAT THE END
RESULT WAS GOING TO BE.
AND I SAY THAT TO YOU BECAUSE AS
YOU THINK ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
WE FACE TODAY.
AND YOU THINK ABOUT ALL THE
THINGS THAT FOLKS TELL US WHY
YOU DON'T DO THAT YOU KNOW
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
THE SAME THING HAPPENED HAPPENED
LAST TIME THEY'LL TAKE YOU OFF
THE BOOKS ARE GOING TO GIVE YOU
A TICKET AND IN NOT GOING TO GET
ANY FURTHER AND WAS STILL GOING
TO BE IN THE SAME CONDITION. SO
WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS.
AND WE ARE CONFRONTED WITH THAT
REALITY AS WE TALK ABOUT CHANGE
AND PROGRESS AND PROGRESS OF
THINGS IN THIS HOUSE. SO THEY'RE
GONNA DO THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER.
AND WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT THOSE
WHO CONTINUE TO PERSIST.
AND YET ROSA PARKS STOOD UP
BECAUSE IT WAS HER TIME AND HER
AND HER PERSISTENCE THAT
EVENTUALLY BECAME THE ONE DROP
OF WATER THAT CREATED THE FLOOD.
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THAT
OFTENTIMES PEOPLE SAY DOCTOR
WEBER WHEN WILL YOU GIVE UP.
WILL YOU GIVE IN ABOUT THE
EDUCATION OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA AND THIS
NATION.
WHEN WILL YOU START TALKING
ABOUT THAT CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
WHEN WE START TALKING ABOUT STOP
TALKING ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
WHEN WILL YOU DO THAT.
AND I HAVE TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT
I AM THE DAUGHTER OF THE ROSA
PARKS OF THE WORLD.
I AM THE PERSISTENT KNOCK AT THE
DOOR FOR JUSTICE AND EQUALITY.
AND YOU SHOULD BE THE ROSA PARKS
OF THE WORLD TO.
BECAUSE A VISIT RIGHT IF IT IS
JUST IT IS OUR TIME TO CONTINUE
TO NOT THAT THE DOORS OF
INEQUALITY.
AND IT IS OUR TIME TO DEMAND
JUSTICE AND FREEDOM FOR
EVERYONE.
SO I MIX EXCITED ALWAYS WHEN I
TALK ABOUT PEOPLE LIKE ROSA
PARKS.
BECAUSE THIS IS A SMALL WOMAN
DOING A GREAT THING.
AND WE LOOK BACK ON IT NOW AND
THINK ABOUT WHAT SHE REALLY THAT
COURAGEOUS YES SHE WAS.
BECAUSE SHE WAS FIGHTING THE
MOST POWERFUL FORCE IN THE
WORLD.
AND THEY COULD HAVE CRUSHED HER
AND WE MAY WOULD HAVE NEVER
HEARD OF HER AGAIN.
SIGH I ASKED YOU TO BE THE ROSA
PARKS OF THIS HOUSE.
TO STAND FOR JUSTICE
A STAND FOR EQUALITY AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HEARD BECAUSE IT IS
TRULY OUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER DOCTOR
EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM.
I ALSO STAND ON BEHALF THE LGBT
CAUCUS AS WE TALK ABOUT ROSA
PARKS TODAY. AND ALSO AS A AS
LIKE DOCTOR WEBER I'M ALSO AN
EDUCATOR AND ONE I WOULD STAND
IN FRONT OF MY STUDENTS AND TALK
ABOUT SIGNIFICANT PEOPLE I WANT
TO KNOW ALSO ABOUT THE CONTEXT
OF THEIR LIFE.
I WANNA KNOW WHO THEY ARE AS
THAT FULL PERSON.
SOCIAL WORKERS YOU TO WORK WITH
PEOPLE IN THE FULL CONTEXT OF
THEIR LIFE.
STILL WHEN I THINK ABOUT ROSA
PARKS I ALSO THINK ABOUT THE
YOUNG GIRL WHO WAS TIED DEEPLY
TO HER FAITH WHO FELT WHO FOUND
FAITH IN THE A IN THE CHURCH.
AND BEGAN ORGANIZING THEIR.
I THINK ABOUT THE YOUNG GIRL WHO
HAD TO DROP OUT OF SCHOOL A
LITTLE BIT EARLY BECAUSE SHE HAD
TO CARE FOR HER MOTHER AND HER
GRANDMOTHER DURING TIMES OF
ILLNESS.
AND THEN I THINK ABOUT HER
HAVING A JOB AND GOING AND
WORKING WITH AND DOUBLE ACP AND
ON THAT DAY ON THAT BUS.
SHE SAT BEHIND THE LINE.
SHE SAT BEHIND THE LINE THAT
SAID BLACKS ONLY.
BUT WHEN MORE PEOPLE GOT ON THE
BUS MEMBERS THEY MOVED THE LINE.
THEY MOVE THE LINE BEFORE HER
AND HOW MANY OF US HAVE BEEN IN
SITUATIONS WHERE WE THINK WE'VE
ACHIEVED WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE. AND SOMEBODY MOVES THE LINE.
AND AT SOME POINT YOU SAY NO.
I WILL NOT CONTINUE TO TAKE THE
BACKSEAT WHEN THE LINE IS MOVED
AFTER I HAVE DONE EVERYTHING
APPROPRIATE.
AND THEN YOU THINK ABOUT. WHAT
WE WERE WE CELEBRATE HER TODAY
BUT AT THAT TIME BECAUSE SHE WAS
A WOMAN? HER VOICE WASN'T REALLY
HEARD.
WHEN A STANDING OVATION WAS
CREATED WHEN SHE WALKED INTO A
ROOM AFTER IN SHE SAID SHOULD I
SPEAK.
AND THE MEN WHO WORK AT WHO WERE
WONDERFUL ACTIVISTS SAID YOU'VE
SAID ENOUGH.
AND SO AFTER THAT SHE WAS FIRED
FROM HER JOB.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THAT SHE WAS
FIRED FROM HER JOB WE KNOW
PEOPLE NOW WHO SPEAK OUT AND
FACED SEVERE RETALIATION.
AND NEVERTHELESS
SHE PERSISTED.
HER HUSBAND WAS GIVEN DEATH
THREATS.
SO EVEN THOUGH SHE WAS AN ICON
OF THE SOUTH IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT. SHE HAD MOVED NORTH
LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHERE THERE
WAS MORE OPPORTUNITY.
WHEN SHE RETURNED TO SCHOOL AT
THAT TIME.
DEVELOPED A BIGGER EDUCATION.
AND THEN AT THAT TIME WENT TO
WORK FOR AN ELECTED OFFICIAL.
REACH BACK TO THE SOUTH.
A BUILDER A NETWORK IN IN
DETROIT.
AT THAT TIME BEING THE FIRST AT
JOHN CONNORS FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN ELECTED TO CONGRESS.
AND SHE WAS ITS FIRST SECRETARY
EVEN THOUGH HE HAD OPINIONS THAT
SAID WOMEN SHOULDN'T BE IN THE
WORKPLACE.
BUT HE KNEW SHE WAS THE BEST
SECRETARY AROUND IS THAT HE MADE
THAT EXCEPTION.
PERSISTED SHE MAY CHANGE
SHOULDN'T STOP.
SHE HAD LEAVE AGAIN.
TO CARE FOR HER MOTHER. AND HER
HUSBAND.
AS A LOT OF WOMEN WHO HAVE
BECOME CARETAKERS CAREGIVERS.
BECAUSE WHEN PEOPLE LOOK AROUND
WHO'S GOING TO CARE FOR OUR
SENIORS WHO'S GOING TO CARE FOR
OUR LOVED ONES.
IT WAS ALSO PEOPLE LIKE ROSA
PARKS LIVING EVERYDAY LIVES
DOING THE RIGHT THING EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
AFTER SHE WAS A SENIOR SHE WAS
LIVING ALONE THEIR OWN HOME. AND
LIKE A WOMAN IN THE OWN
SOUTHSIDE STOCK IN A JUST
OCCURRED IN MY DISTRICT.
SHE WAS ASSAULTED. BY A YOUNG
PERSON.
PULLING HER INTO THINKING HE WAS
TRYING TO HELP.
SHE WAS ASSAULTED WHEN SHE WAS
IN HER LATE SEVENTIES LIVING
ALONE INDEPENDENTLY IN DETROIT
AND AT THAT TIME THEN WAS MOVED
INTO INTO A DIFFERENT KIND OF
HOUSING.
SO WHILE SHE DID THIS ONE GREAT
THING THAT WE ALL REMEMBER.
LET US NEVER FORGET THE FULL
LIFE SHE LIVED THAT IS SYMBOLIC
OF THE STRUGGLES WE STILL FACE
IF YOU ARE AN AFRICAN AMERICAN.
IF YOU'RE A WOMAN.
ALL OF THESE THINGS AND THEN
BECOMING A SENIOR ALSO PUT YOU
IN ANOTHER VULNERABLE SITUATION.
SO AS WE CONTINUE TO STAND FOR
ROSA PARKS ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT SHE
DID LET US NEVER FORGET THAT THE
STRUGGLE CONTINUES.
ON ALL KINDS OF LEVELS
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES FOR US ALL
TO BE GREAT.
IF ONLY WERE WILLING TO SERVE
AND TO LIVE OUR LIVES OF QUIET
DIGNITY EVERY SINGLE DAY. ON
BEHALF OF THE LGBT CAUCUS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
DOCTOR EGGMAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR LEVIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS I RISE.
SUPPORT OF HR SEVENTY THREE ROSA
PARKS.
IS A SYMBOL OF JUSTICE.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO RECOGNIZE
FOR STRENGTH AND COMMITMENT TO
FIGHT. FOR EQUALITY.
HER REFUSAL TO MOVE TO THE BACK
OF THE BUS.
WAS HEROIC.
MEMBERS THERE IS DANGER IN THE
AIR AT THIS MOMENT.
THE INSIDIOUS IDEA.
THAT SOME PEOPLE ARE LESS EQUAL
THAN OTHERS.
HAS REARED ITS UGLY HEAD IN OUR
COUNTRY.
WE MUST KEEP ROSA PARKS MEMORY
ALIVE.
WE MUST NOT RETURN
THE PAST.
AMERICA'S GREATNESS IS IN THE
FUTURE THAT ROSA PARKS.
FOR.
I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD AND AYE
ASPIRIN AYE THOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER IRVING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THURMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR
SEVENTY THREE.
I LIKE TO THANK. MY COLLEAGUE.
I'M SAN BENITO FOR BRING IT
FORWARD.
AND I TO ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
REMARKS OF MY DISTINGUISHED
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO AND HER
POWERFUL REMARKS
ON BEHALF OF THIS RESOLUTION.
I'M PROUD TO RISE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
LATINO CAUCUS TODAY. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF HR SEVENTY THREE.
IT IS AN HONOR FOR US TO
CELEBRATE. THE BIRTHDAY AND THE
LEGACY OF A GREAT AMERICAN AND
CIVIL RIGHTS HERO ROSA PARKS.
AS MANY OF YOU HAVE OUTLINED.
SHE IS MOST FAMOUS FOR HER
PROTESTS.
ON A BUS
IN MONTGOMERY.
WHERE SHE PAID HER FARE?
WHERE SHE SAT IN THE SO CALLED
SECTION WHERE SHE WAS SUPPOSED
TO SIT?
AND BECAUSE OTHER PASSENGERS
WHITE PASSENGERS WERE.
MADE THE STAND.
THE DRIVER TOLD HER AND OTHER
AFTER AMERICAN PASSENGERS.
YOU MUST GET UP.
AND MOVE
TO ACCOMMODATE OTHERS.
SHE INDEED DEDICATED HER ENTIRE
LIFE.
TO A FIGHT FOR JUSTICE.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
WHEN.
CALLED IN THAT SITUATION.
WHEN YOU KNOW THAT YOU FACE.
ARREST.
AND LITERALLY DEATH THREATS AS
ROSA PARKS DID FOR MANY MANY
YEARS.
IN THE FACE OF IT ALL.
AND IN THE FACE OF
DISCRIMINATION.
SHE URGED THE DETERMINATION TO
NEVER ACCEPTED.
EVEN IF IT MUST BE INDOOR.
IN HER OWN WORDS
ROSA PARKS
WAS ON A SEARCH FOR AWAY WORKING
FOR FREEDOM AND FIRST CLASS
CITIZENSHIP.
BECAUSE NO INTELLIGENT RIGHT
THINKING PERSON IS SATISFIED
WITH LESS THAN HUMAN RIGHTS THAT
ARE ENJOYED BY ALL PEOPLE.
HOW FITTING THEN THEIR WE
CELEBRATE HER LEGACY AT A TIME
WHERE MANY OF US ARE FACING
TREATMENT? THAT EQUATES
A SECOND CLASS CITIZENSHIP.
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OUR
DHAKA IN DREAMER FAMILY MEMBERS.
THE POOR.
THE HOMELESS.
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO ARE
STILL FACING DISCRIMINATION.
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S MUCH WORK
TO BE DONE TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
ALL TREATED EQUALLY.
WE'VE COME A LONG WAY SINCE
DECEMBER FIRST NINETEEN FIFTY
FIVE. BUT WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO
GO.
I URGE THIS BODY TO STAY
DETERMINED TO NEVER ACCEPT. LESS
THAN EQUALITY FOR ALL.
OUR DIVERSITY MAKES AS BEAUTIFUL
AND STRONG.
BUT WE SHOULD NEVER.
THAT DIFFERENCE IS DIVIDE US.
LET US WORK TO ENSURE THAT NO
ONE FEELS THE PAIN. OF BEING
LESS THAN.
LET US HONOR THE LEGACY OF ROSA
PARKS BY PUSHING FOR ONE
CALIFORNIA AND ONE AMERICA
WITHOUT DIVISION I URGE AYE
VOTE.
ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER THURMAN.
MEMBERS MS REYES HAS ASKED FOR A
CO AUTHORS FOR THIS RESOLUTION.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE
.
QUICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS ON
THIS RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS WE CAN I TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE ANY
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
IT BRINGS UP FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY FOUR BY
SOMETHING AMBER CERVANTES AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
GIRLS AND WOMEN IN SPORTS WEEK.
CERVANTES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AN
MEMBERS I PROBABLY RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS IN ALONGSIDE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM WINTERS TO PRESENT HR
SEVENTY FOUR.
HR SEVENTY FOUR PROCLAIMS
JANUARY TWENTY NINTH THROUGH
FEBRUARY FOURTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
HAS CALIFORNIA GIRLS AND WOMEN
IN SPORTS WEEK.
THIS RESOLUTION SPEAKS TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF EQUALITY INCLUSION
AND FEMALE EMPOWERMENT.
RECOGNIZING THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
OF GIRLS AND WOMEN IN
PROFESSIONAL COLLEGIATE.
CLUB HIGH SCHOOL YOUTH AND
RECREATIONAL SPORTS IS CRITICAL
TO BREAKING DOWN BARRIERS WE
FACE WITH IN THE SPORTING ARENA
AND TO WHAT FOLLOWS US OUTSIDE
IN OUR DAILY LIVES.
REFLECTING UPON MY PARTICIPATION
IN SPORTS AS A YOUNG GIRL. AYE
REQUIRED SO MANY LIFE SKILLS
FROM LEARNING. TEAMWORK GOAL
SETTING DEDICATION TIME
MANAGEMENT PERSEVERANCE AND
RESILIENCE.
AS WITH ANY THEME THERE'S ALWAYS
CHALLENGES SUCH AS TOUGH LOSSES
AN INCREDIBLE SACRIFICES THAT
NEED TO BE MADE.
BUT SPORTS PROVIDE US WITH THE
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN FROM
THESE CHALLENGES.
AND WORK TOGETHER WITH YOUR
TEAMMATES AND BETTER AND BECOME
BETTER BECAUSE OF THAT.
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY
SPORTS AS A YOUNG GIRL.
HAS LED.
TOO MANY POSITIVE EXPERIENCES
AND HAS BEEN A POSITIVE IMPACT
IN MY LIFE.
AND SO I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY YOUNG GIRL OUT THERE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN THEIR
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES.
TO THE GIRLS OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
INTO THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS RESOLUTION IS
FOR YOU.
TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR COURAGE TO
COMPETE IMPOSTOR THAT
COMPETITIVE SPIRIT WE ALL KNOW
IS NECESSARY TO WIN LIKE A GIRL.
PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY IN
CELEBRATING CALIFORNIA GIRLS AND
WOMEN IN SPORTS WEEK I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
FAMOUS CERVANTES MS AG OCCURRING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
AS A MEMBER OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS AND JOINT AUTHORED THIS
RESOLUTION.
PARTICIPATION IN SPORTS IS
INCREDIBLE WAY TO LEARN. LIVE
SUCH SKILL OF TEAMWORK.
LEADERSHIP AND CONFIDENCE.
WE SHOULD ALL BE ENCOURAGING
GIRLS AND WOMEN TO PARTICIPATE
AND TO COMPETE IN THE SPORT
PLAYING SPORTS AT ALL LEVELS AT
ALL LEVELS THEY'RE VERY POSITIVE
VOICE TO.
BRING OUT AND ENCOURAGING YOUNG
GIRLS TO GET OUT OF THERE FOR A
REGULAR FRAMEWORK.
I AM I AM A MOTHER OF TWO
DAUGHTERS AND I WANT TO TELL YOU
I SPENT YEARS ON OF LEECHERS IN
THE BLEACHERS WATCHING MY GIRLS
PLAY.
MY DAUGHTER MEGAN.
IS AN INCREDIBLE ATHLETE.
SHE ALWAYS COMPETED ON THE BOYS
TEAM IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
PEOPLE LOOKED DOWN AT HER AND
LOOKED DOWN AT ME FOR LETTING MY
DAUGHTER PLAY ON THE BOYS TEAM.
THERE WAS A GIRLS TEAM SHE'S
VERY COMPETITIVE THE START THE
TEAM.
IT'S YOU HAVE TO HAVE A LOT OF
RESILIENCE AS SHE WENT THROUGH
ALL THE SPORTS ALWAYS COMPETING
WITH THE BOYS.
AND I WAS HAVING TO WEAR BOY'S
UNIFORM BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T MAKE
GIRLS UNIFORMS.
MY DAUGHTER TODAY I'M PROUD THE
SHOES IN INDIANAPOLIS.
INDIANA THIS MORNING SHE IS
PRESENTING TO ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE IN THE A DS
CORPORATION SHE DOES WOMEN'S
MARKETING AND ACTIVATION FOR
THEIR UNIFORMS.
SO.
I JUST WANT TO HONOR HER AS
WELL AS ALL THE OTHER YOUNG
WOMEN THAT HAVE WORKED HARD IT'S
BEEN A TOUGH TIME BECAUSE A.
BUTTER I'M I THINK MANY OF US
MIGHT REMEMBER WE DID NOISE OF
THE BEST UNIFORMS AS THE WOMEN
PLAYING ON THE SPORT RIGHT WE
HAD THESE THINGS CALL PIN. OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT SO.
I RESPECTFULLY ACTS ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
TAKING HIS IDEA CURRY SUMMER
BAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND THANK YOU
TO MEMBERS ARE CORONA WINTERS
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AYE.
AND PLEASE TO AUTHOR AND I
THINK THEY'RE BOTH TERRIFIC
AUTHORS OF THIS RESOLUTION NOT
ONLY FOR BEING A CHEERLEADER ON
THE SIDELINES FOR HER DAUGHTER'S
MEMBER FROM WINTERS. BUT THAT
MEMBER FROM CRYING HIS GREAT
ATHLETIC EXPERIENCES WELL I
THINK IT IS. WE WOULD BE REMISS
NOT TO POINT SOMETHING OUT ABOUT
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN SPORTS.
AND THAT IS THE GROSS PAY
DISPARITY.
THAT WOMEN IN SPORTS EXPERIENCE.
AND TOMORROW I THINK IS
GROUNDHOG DAY SO I'M GONNA TAKE
A MOMENT TO JUST REMIND US ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE WE SHOULD JUST
SHINE A SPOTLIGHT ON IT. EVERY
SINGLE OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE.
AND ONE OF THE BEST EXAMPLES IS
THE WOMEN'S TEAM IN SOCCER.
WHICH ONE THAT TWENTY FIFTEEN
WORLD CUP.
AND AS YOU MAY KNOW. A THEY HAD
TO SPLIT AMONG THEMSELVES TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR WINNING THE
MOST WATCHED SPORTS GAME IN
HISTORY IN THE WORLD. THE MEN
MADE NINE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
LOSING AND ROUND SIXTEEN.
THE WOMEN PLAY MORE EXHIBITION
GAMES THEY'RE ONLY PAID IF
THEY'D LOSE IF THEY WIN THE
GAMES THE MEN PLAY FEWER
EXHIBITION GAMES THEY ARE PAID
IF THEY LOSE.
AND THEY'RE PAID ALMOST HALF OF
WHAT WOMEN GET IF THEY WHEN THEY
GET PAID FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
WOMEN GET THIRTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONLY IF THEY WIN AN
EXHIBITION GAME.
AND ON TOP OF THAT.
THEY'VE WOMEN'S SOCCER PRODUCES
MORE REVENUE THEY HAVE SOARED
PAST THE MEN'S SOCCER LEAGUE FOR
THE SOCCER LEAGUE THEN THEN THE
MEN'S TEAM DOES I WANT THE MEN
TO DO WELL BUT. THE WOMEN ARE
REALLY TAKING OFF THEY ARE
CHAMPIONS ACROSS THE WORLD THEIR
RECORD IS THAT THEY HAVE WON
MEDALS IN EVERY OLYMPICS SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY SIX.
AND THEY MAKE LESS THAN THE MEN.
AND THEY GET LOWER TRAVELING
ALLOWANCES.
LESS EXPENSIVE OR LESS A FOR
SPONSORSHIP APPEARANCES THEY GET
LOWER WORLD CUP BONUSES LOWER
BONUSES FOR WINNING THEIR OTHER
EXHIBITION GAMES. AND.
IT'S NOT JUST SOCCER BY THE WAY
WHERE THIS IS HAPPENING THE
GENDER WAGE GAP IS GROWING IT'S
NOT GETTING BETTER IT'S GROWING
IN PROFESSIONAL BASKETBALL. AND
PRIZE MONEY IN PROFESSIONAL GOLF
CHAMPIONSHIPS IS LOWER FOR
WOMEN.
AND WOMEN ARE SHORT CHANGED EVEN
AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL. THE NCAA
AWARDS A TOTAL OF ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR MEN'S
BASKETBALL TOURNAMENT VICTORIES
IT AWARDS NOTHING FOR WOMEN.
AND SO IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT WOMEN ARE WINNING MORE
GAMES THEY'RE PLAYING MORE GAMES
THEY'RE EARNING MORE FOR THEIR
SPORTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
THEY'RE PAID LESS TO WIN. THAN
MEN WHEN THEY LOSE.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE HAVE TO
SHINE A SPOTLIGHT ON IT EVERY
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE. BEEN IN
THIS IS MESSED UP.
AND WE OWE IT TO THE WOMEN
ATHLETES OF THE PAST THE PRESENT
AND THE FUTURE TO SHINE THAT
SPOTLIGHT IN THE CALLING OUT
EVERY OPPORTUNITY WE CAN I THINK
THE MEMBER FOR CORONA AND THE
MEMBER FROM WINTERS. FOR GIVING
US AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT I
ENCOURAGE JUST TO BE SURE TO.
POINT THIS OUT EVERY CHANCE WE
GET AND CONSIDER WAYS IN WHICH
WE CAN BE FIGHTING FOR GENDER
EQUALITY IN SPORTS FOR WOMEN AND
GIRLS THINK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
WANT TO THANK OUR PREVIOUS
COLLEAGUE FOR RAISING.
THE ISSUES THAT SHE HAS.
TO SOME EXTENT THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE.
TALKING POINTS THAT I WANTED TO.
I PROJECT OUT THERE BUT SO THANK
YOU BUT I WILL KEEP IT BRIEF I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
RESOLUTION.
AS UP SOMEONE WHO WITNESSED HER
ON AND OFF THE FIELD AS A ROLE
MODEL. OF FOR MANY YOUNG LADIES
I JUST WANTED TO THANK HER FOR
RAISING.
I THIS ISSUE AS A FATHER OF A
YOUNG THREE YEAR OLD THAT I
OFTENTIMES MENTIONED HERE ON.
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR I THINK THIS
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
THAT WE SEND THIS MESSAGE OUT
LOUD AND CLEAR THAT OUR YOUNG
LADIES.
CAN DO WHATEVER THEY WANT.
HOWEVER THEY WANT.
RIGHT AND THAT THAT THEY ARE
CAPABLE OF A COMPETING.
AT ALL FACETS OF LIFE AND SO
THANK YOU.
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE
WHO OUT ON A SIDE NOTE.
WAS THEIR ALL STAR SOFTBALL
PLAYER ALL THE WAY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY DOWN TO.
LITTLE LEAGUE AND I COULD TELL
YOU WHAT THAT THAT IF YOU PUT
ARE OUT ON A BASEBALL FIELD.
OUT WITH ANY OF THE GENTLEMEN
HERE AYE SHE PROBABLY WOULD DIE.
A COMPETE
I IF NOT DOT TAKE IT TO A WHOLE
OTHER LEVEL SO THANK YOU AGAIN
AND I'M HOW PROUD TO US. COOPER
THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER GARCIA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
WOMEN IN SPORTS IS MEANINGFUL TO
NOT ONLY US AS MOTHERS BUT
WATCHING OUR OWN CHILDREN PLAY
BUT TO AS MANY OF US AS
INDIVIDUALS WHO PLAYED SPORTS.
SO I WANT TO TAKE YOU BACK TO
THE EARLY NINETEEN SIXTIES AND
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AN ORANGE
COUNTY AND AS MY FAMILY MOVED
FROM EAST LOS ANGELES AND ORANGE
COUNTY A FAMILY OF TEN. FIVE
BROTHERS AND FOUR SISTERS MY
MOTHER DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO SWIM.
AND SHE TOOK IT VERY SERIOUSLY
TO TEACH US HOW TO SWIM SO AN
ORANGE COUNTY MOVING TO FULLER
TEN OUT WE TOOK SWIMMING
LESSONS.
AND THROUGHOUT THAT TIME SHE
MADE SURE THAT NOT ONLY DID WE
TAKE SWIMMING LESSONS BUT I ALSO
AT THAT TIME IT WAS CALLED.
BOBBY SOCKS NOW IT'S SOFTBALL SO
WE DID THAT ON. ALL OF MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND I.
NOT TOO MUCH LATER IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX UP POOL WAS OPENED
RIGHT DOWN THE BLOCK FROM ME.
THE JANET EVANS SWIMMING COMPLEX
AND AS I WAS INTERESTED IN
SWIMMING I THEN BEGAN TO SWIM
COMPETITIVELY IN JUNIOR HIGH AND
INTO HIGH SCHOOL BUT MY FIRST
YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. I ALSO WANTED TO
PLAY WATER POLO AND AS WAS
ALREADY MENTIONED TODAY THERE
WAS NO WOMEN'S WATER POLO TEAM
ARE GIRLS WATER POLO TEAM. SO I
INDEED PLAYED ON THE GUYS WATER
POLO TEAM AND IT WAS TOUGH.
A AS A FRESHMAN AND SOPHOMORE I
PRETTY MUCH COULD HANDLE PLAYING
AGAINST THE GUYS BUT AS I GOT A
LITTLE BIT OLDER AND THEY GOT.
BIGGER AND STRONGER I DIDN'T DO
AS WELL BUT I STILL KEPT PLANE
AND IS THAT COMPETITIVENESS OF
GETTING UP AT FIVE IN THE
MORNING GOING TO WORK OUT WE
ALSO HAD WORKOUTS IN THE
AFTERNOON. I ALSO HAD TO WORK
OUTSIDE OF SPORTS SO IT REALLY
AS WE SAID IT POT YOU DISCIPLINE
I WASN'T A WINNER.
I WON I SWAM IN A HIGH SCHOOL ON
THE TEAM I DIDN'T WIN ONE RACE.
AND I SWAM FOR FOUR YEARS BUT I
WAS A LONG DISTANCE SWIMMER AND
SOME OF YOU KNOW I STAY AT
THINGS AND EVEN IF I LOSE I KEEP
COMING BACK. BUT I I WANT TO GO
BACK TO OUR ADULT.
TIME THAT AS I AS I DID THAT I
ALSO SWAM ON OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TEAM AND THEN LATER ON.
WAS A TEACHER IN ONE OF MY UP
PROUDEST MEMORIES AS A TEACHER
IS THAT BECAUSE I WAS ON THE
FULLERTON CITY COUNCIL WE MADE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THAT SAME POLL
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX. THAT I
SWAM ON TO TEACH MY OWN STUDENTS
TO SWIM AND OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY STUDENTS WELL I'M ON THAT
LOCAL PARK POOL AND MANY OF THEM
HAD NEVER SWAM BEFORE SO. THAT
IS INDEED SOMETHING I'M VERY
PROUD OF BUT MOVING ALL THE WAY
BACK HERE TO THE STATE ASSEMBLY
AND.
TWENTY AYE ELEVEN.
AN OPPONENT OF MINE STOOD ON
THIS FLOOR AS WE WERE
CELEBRATING BRANDI CHASTAIN.
THE FAMOUS SOCCER PLAYER.
WHO KICK TO THAT GOAL IN AND
ACTUALLY ROSE AND TALKED ABOUT
HOW TITLE NINE HAD NOT WORKED?
A I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
WE A MEDIA LEE.
DISAGREED WITH THAT AND MADE IT
NO ONE THAT WE'RE NOT GOING
BACKWARDS WITH WOMEN'S SPORTS
AYE IS SO. AS I A LOOK AT SPORTS
YOU NEVER KNOW WHERE THOSE
SPORTS IN THOSE UP TRAITS FROM
DISCIPLINE TIP PERSEVERANCE AND
TO COMPETITIVENESS OR GOING TO
FIND THEIR WAY AND FOR ME IT'S
FOUND MY WAY TO THIS ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF HR SEVENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAKE THIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS AFTER HEARING THE GREAT
TESTIMONY FROM.
ARE MEMBER IN COACHELLA TALKING
ABOUT HIS THREE YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER AS A FATHER I MUST TO
RISE AND SPEAK ABOUT MY THREE
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER. ON SHE
COMPETES IN JIM CANA WHICH IS A
HORSEBACK RIDING COMPETITION.
AND THOUGH SHE MAY HAVE SIX
BROTHERS SHE ALRIGHT ALL OF
THEM.
ON WITH THE TRUE NATURE IN.
I JUST LOOK FORWARD. TO
SUPPORTING ANY OPPORTUNITY WE
CAN HAVE.
TO SEE OUR YOUNG WOMEN.
THRIVE AND SUCCEED IN HOW THE
SAME OPPORTUNITY AS THE GUYS.
LAKE SPECIALLY LOVE WATCHING HER
COME IN WITH A SMILE AND A WAVE.
AND HER BROTHER'S GOING HOW COME
SO I SEE COMPLETELY SUPPORT HR
SEVENTY FOUR.
AGES LET'S MAKE SURE WE CAN KEEP
OUR WOMAN GOING. IN GIVE THE
BOYS HELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MATHIS.
NEVER SEEN NO FURTHER DEBATE.
THE CERVANTES IS ASKING.
TO OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS.
A QUICK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE. THERE
ARE SIXTY NINE CO AUTHORS.
WILL NOT TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THE RESOLUTION.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT IN THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'LL
PASS RETAIN THEM PASS AND RETAIN
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN.
INCIDENT THIRD READING MEMBERS
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON HOT FILE
ITEMS ELEVEN THROUGH FOURTEEN.
NUMBER SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS OF FRIDAY FEBRUARY
SECOND NO FLOOR SESSION.
A NO CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY
FEBRUARY FIFTH FLOOR SESSION AT
ONE P. M..
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS FOR
GRANTED.
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK IN A
GERMAN INSTRUMENT IN MEMORY
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
FOR THE ADJOURNMENT AND
MEMORIES.
START THIS MORNING WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COSTING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF CALVIN
EDWARDS THOMAS.
CALLUM WAS BORN ON FEBRUARY
FOURTH NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT AND
PASSED AWAY TRAGICALLY ON
DECEMBER EIGHTEENTH
TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
AT THE AGE OF SEVENTEEN CALVET
LEFT HIGH SCHOOL DURING HIS
SENIOR YEAR TO ENLIST IN THE
ARMY HOPING TO BECOME A
PARATROOPER. HE WAS DEPLOYED TO
VIETNAM IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
AS A SPARK AS PART OF A SPECIAL
FORCES TWELVE MAN UNIT
RESPONSIBLE FOR TRAINING
CIVILIANS. TO FIGHT TO FIGHT
VIET CONG COMMUNIST FIGHTERS.
IN DECEMBER OF NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT A GROUP OF VIET CONG
GUERRILLA FIGHTERS ATTACKED THE
VILLAGE WHERE CALVIN WAS
TRAINING CIVILIANS BUT HE AND A
FEW OTHER GREEN BERETS WERE ABLE
TO ESCAPE INTO THE SURROUNDING
FOREST.
THE SURVIVORS EIGHT INSECTS
MUSHROOMS AND FROGS TO SURVIVE
AS THEY WERE WITHOUT ANY FOOD OR
AMMUNITION UNTIL THEY WERE
RESCUED.
WHILE IN VIETNAM HE CONTRACT HE
CONTRACTED ENCEPHALITIS AND WAS
HONORABLY DISCHARGED FROM THE
ARMY ON DECEMBER TWENTY THIRD
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
AFTER HIS DISCHARGE CALVIN
INITIALLY HAD TROUBLE
READJUSTING TO CIVILIAN LIFE.
BUT AFTER TRAVELING AROUND
CALIFORNIA RETURNED TO HIS
PARENTS HOME TO LEARN HIS
FATHER'S TRADE OF CARPENTRY.
AT THE YOUNG AGE OF TWENTY FOUR
CALVIN WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
PARKINSON'S AS A RESULT OF HIS
ILLNESS IN VIETNAM.
I SPENT THE NEXT FORTY FIVE
YEARS OF HIS LIFE WITH HIS
FAMILY PURSUING DIFFERENT
REMEDIES AND UNDERGOING SEVERAL
NEUROLOGICAL SURGERIES.
HIS BROTHER GEORGE CARED FOR HIM
EVEN MOVING CALVIN TO HIS OWN
HOME AS THE DISEASE CONTINUE TO
PROGRESS.
BUT EVENTUALLY HE WAS MOVING TO
THE VETERANS ADMINISTRATION
CONVALESCENT HOME IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY THIS PAST
DECEMBER.
UNFORTUNATELY HE PASSED AWAY.
GEORGE ONE SAID THROUGH ALL OF
HIS TRIALS AND TRIBULATIONS OVER
THE YEARS. MY BROTHER EVER EVER
COMPLAINED
ABOUT HIS LOT IN LIFE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN TODAY SESSION IN MEMORY
OF A GREAT MAN.
CALVIN EDWARDS THOMAS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MR ACOSTA.
MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER UP AT THANK YOU
AND MISTER SPEAKER I'M GONNA
LEAVE US SINGING TO THE
PROFESSIONALS BUT I REQUEST
PERMISSION TO RECITE SOME
LYRICS.
MISSION WHEN IT.
THANK YOU IT IT'S ALRIGHT IF YOU
LOVED ME IT'S ALRIGHT IF YOU
DON'T.
I'M NOT AFRAID OF YOU RUN IN NO
WAY HONEY I'VE GOT THIS FEELING
YOU WON'T AND.
MEMBERS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
WITH THESE INTRODUCTORY LINES
FROM THE SONG BREAKDOWN.
TOM PETTY THE HEARTBREAKERS
BURST ONTO THE STAGE AND NEVER
STOPPED WRITING MISTER PETTY
NEVER STOPPED WRITING RECORDING
AND PERFORMING TO MILLIONS OF
LOYAL FANS UNTIL IS UNTIMELY
DEATH. ON OCTOBER SECOND.
AND MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
IF IT WASN'T OBVIOUS I'M ONE OF
THOSE FANS AND.
SO IT IS WITH GREAT SADNESS AND
A PROFOUND SENSE OF APPRECIATION
THAT I ISE TO ADJOURN THE
MEMORY OF ROCK AND ROLL LEGEND
TOM PETTY.
I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO ATTEND THE
HEARTBREAKERS PENULTIMATE
PERFORMANCE AT THE HOLLYWOOD
BOWL IN SEPTEMBER.
SPEAKING TO THE CROWD DURING A
SET THE COVERED MEMORABLE SONGS
WRITTEN AND RECORDED OVER THE
COURSE OF SEVERAL DECADES OF
CREATIVITY. PETTY OBSERVE THAT
WHILE HE IN THE MEMBERS OF THE
BAND WERE ORIGINALLY FROM
FLORIDA.
THEY HAD LONG AGO MOVED AND.
TOM PETTY AND THE HEARTBREAKERS.
AREN'T LA BANDS
AND THE PARTISAN AUDIENCE ROARED
ITS APPROVAL.
TOM PETTY WAS BORN ON OCTOBER
TWENTIETH NINETEEN FIFTY IN
GAINESVILLE FLORIDA.
HIS INTEREST IN ROCK AND ROLL
WAS SPARKED AT THE AGE OF TEN
WHEN HIS UNCLE WHO WAS WORKING
ON A FILM WITH ELVIS PRESLEY.
INVITED HIM TO THE SHOES.
THEIR PETTY MET PRESLEY AND IN
WHAT HE DESCRIBED AS A LIFE
ALTERING MOMENT.
HE THEN GOT HIS FIRST GUITAR.
AND SOON AFTER EMBARKED ON A
CAREER.
FOR THE PAST FORTY YEARS PETTY
HAS MADE DEEPLY MOVING RELATABLE
AND TIMELESS MUSIC MAINTAINING A
STEADY SONG WRITING AND TOURING
SCHEDULE.
WITH INFLUENCES THAT INCLUDED
THE BEATLES THE ROLLING STONES
AND BOB DYLAN. HE SEAMLESSLY
MERGED ROCK AND ROLL WITH
COUNTRY ELEMENTS THAT REFLECTED
HIS SOUTHERN ROOTS.
HIS SOLO ALBUMS OFTEN FEATURED
MEMBERS OF THE HEARTBREAKERS AND
IN THE LATE NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
JOIN THE TRAVELING WILBURYS
A GROUP THAT INCLUDED SUPERSTARS
GEORGE HARRISON ROY ORBISON. AND
BOB DYLAN.
HIT ALSO RECENTLY REFORMED ONE
OF HIS EARLIER BANDS MUDCRUTCH.
OVER THE COURSE OF HIS CAREER.
PETTY PRODUCED THREE SOLO ALBUMS
AND THIRTEEN ALBUMS WITH THE
HEARTBREAKERS MANY OF WHICH WERE
CERTIFIED GOLD DEPRIVE OUR
PLATINUM.
IN TWO THOUSAND TO HE AND THE
HEARTBREAKERS WERE INDUCTED INTO
THE ROCK AND ROLL HALL OF FAME.
HE CONTINUED DOING WHAT HE LOVED
RIGHT UP TO THE END AND WAS
FEROCIOUSLY DEDICATED TO HIS
FANS.
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT PETTY'S
FAMILY ANNOUNCED RECENTLY.
THAT HE PERFORMED MUCH OF ITS
FINAL TO HER WITH A WITH A
FRACTURED HIP AND OTHER PAINFUL
INJURIES.
BUT STEADFASTLY REFUSE TO REDUCE
HIS SCHEDULE.
IT WAS THESE INJURIES THAT LED
INTO USE PRESCRIBED OPIOID.
PAINKILLERS WHICH IN TURN LEAD
TO IS ACCIDENTAL. AND UNTIMELY
DEATH.
A PASSED AWAY.
IN ON OCTOBER SECOND AT THE AGE
OF SIXTY SIX.
LEAVING BEHIND AN IMMENSE AND
TIMELESS ROCK MUSIC LEGACY.
HE SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE BROTHER
TWO DAUGHTERS A STEPSON AND
GRANDCHILD. AND I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER BLUE.
MR HOLDING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE
TO GERMAN IN THE MEMORY OF
DOCTOR FLOORING INGRAM STEVENS
WHO PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF
FIFTY THREE.
DOCTOR STEVENS EMBARKED ON HER
CAREER IN THE FIELD OF EDUCATION
AS AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER
IN NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE.
LATER SWITCHING CAREER PASS
AFTER EARNING HER DOCTORATE OF
EDUCATION FROM UCLA.
AFTER BEGINNING HER CAREER.
AT ELLIS A LA U. S. D. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE SHE WORKED
HER WAY UP AND RETIRED. IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR AS DIRECTOR
RESEARCH AND EVALUATION
A POSITION SHE HELD FOR NINETEEN
YEARS.
IN ADDITION DOCTOR STEVENS
ESTABLISH OUR OWN BUSINESS FLORA
LEAN AYE STEVENS AND ASSOCIATES.
THROUGHOUT HER LIFETIME DOCTOR
STEVENS GAVE GENEROUSLY OVER
TIME AND ENERGY TO VARIOUS
CAUSES DEAR TO HER HEART.
INCLUDING LINKS INK.
THE PASADENA CITY COLLEGE
FOUNDATION. AND THE LULLABY
GUILD.
AMONG HER MANY EFFORTS TO HELP
OTHERS ACHIEVE THEIR HIGHEST
POTENTIAL ESPECIALLY AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN. DOCTOR STEPHEN
SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF THE DELTA
SIGMA THETA SORORITY AND AS
PRESIDENT OF THE EBONY GUILD.
SHE WAS NOT ONLY A SPIRITED
EDUCATOR ADMINISTRATOR AND
ENTREPRENEUR. SHE WAS ALSO A
MENTOR MOTIVATOR AND MOTHER.
DOCTOR FLORA LEAN INGRAM STEVENS
LEAVES A LEGACY WHOSE GENEROSITY
WAS EXTENDED TO EVERYONE WITHOUT
HESITATION.
WE'RE THE ONLY REWARD FOR HER
WORK WAS RAISING HER COMMUNITY
TO BE PRIME EXAMPLES. OF
SELFLESSNESS AND GOOD WILL.
DOCTOR FLOOR LEAN STEVENS IS
SURVIVED BY HER DAUGHTER MELBA
CHERYL CHARLENE STEVENS AND HER
SON. RONALD STEVENS AND A HOST
OF OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS AND
FRIENDS.
I THINK YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR
COSTUMES OR IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON US
RIGHT ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
PLEASE A JOIN ME.
I IN. ADJOINING IN MEMORY OF A
MAN WHO SERVED THE CITY OF
CLOVIS FOR NEARLY. FIFTY YEARS.
HARRY ARMSTRONG WAS ONE OF THE
LONGEST SERVING CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA.
HE PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY
EIGHTEENTH THAT EIGHTY SEVEN
YEARS OLD.
AND HE LEFT HIS MARK ON OUR
COMMUNITY YOU CAN SEE IT ALL
AROUND IN THE FORM OF HIGHWAYS
HOSPITALS POLICE AND FIRE
DEPARTMENTS.
IN ALL THOSE YEARS HARRY WAS
RECOGNIZED BY GRATEFUL COMMUNITY
WITH REELECTION AFTER REELECTION
TWELVE CONSECUTIVE FOUR YEAR
TERMS.
WAS ALSO ELECTED THE CLOTHES
HALL OF FAME AND TWENTY TEN.
NAME THE GRAND MARSHAL OF THE
CLOVIS RODEO IN TWENTY FIFTEEN.
MEMBERS ARE. PUBLIC SERVICE
SERVER LIKE HARRY.
DOESN'T COME AROUND ALL THAT
OFTEN. THE CLOVIS COMMUNITY IS
WHAT IT IS TODAY BECAUSE OF HIS
DEDICATION YEAR IN AND YEAR OUT.
HE HAS BEEN TERMED BY MANY. AS
A.
THE ONE INDIVIDUAL WHO PROBABLY
HAS WOVEN MORE IN THE TAPESTRY
OF CLOVIS.
THEN ANY OTHER.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN WITH US WE
ARE SADDENED BY HIS LOSS.
BUT WE ARE REMEMBER MAY HAVE
CARRIED OUT ARMSTRONG FONDLY FOR
THE LIFE VERY VERY WELL LIVED A
LIFE OF PUBLIC SERVICE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON OUR
FINAL GERMAN MEMORY.
MR MACE ARE RECOGNIZED THAN
MISTER BLOOM.
THE MISTER SPEAKER THE MEMBERS I
RISE TO GERMAN IN MEMORY. OF
RABBI ISAIAH ZELDIN OF PALM
DESERT.
RABBI ZELDIN DIED PEACEFULLY AT
HIS HOME SURROUNDED BY HIS
FAMILY. AND WAS LAID TO REST ON
MONDAY HE WAS NINETY SEVEN.
ONE OF RABBIS AL-DIN'S GREATEST
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IS FOUNDING THE
STEPHEN S. WISE TEMPLE IN LOS
ANGELES
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR WHICH
GREW TO BECOME ONE OF THE
LARGEST REFORM SYNAGOGUES.
IN THE COUNTRY.
THE CONGREGATION BECAME KNOWN
FOR ITS EXTENSIVE EDUCATIONAL IN
SERVICE PROGRAMS PARENTING
CENTER LIBRARY SWIMMING POOL BUS
SERVICE AND OTHER SERVICES
DESIGNED FOR FAMILIES. OF ALL
AGES.
RETIRED FROM THEIR NINETEEN
NINETY.
RABBI ZELDIN IS SURVIVED BY HIS
FOUR CHILDREN JOLE KAREN MICHEL
AND TERRY.
HIS BROTHER BERNARD AND AND HIS
EIGHT GRANDCHILDREN AND SEVEN
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AND ASK THAT WE JOIN IN
HIS MEMORY.
HELLO THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
I JOIN IN.
GUY ASKING THAT WE ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF OTHER GREAT RABBI
ISAIAH ZELDA AND. THE STEVEN S.
WISE TEMPLE WHICH HE.
AS MENTIONED FOUNDED IS IN MY
DISTRICT AND SERVES THOUSANDS OF
MY CONSTITUENTS AND IT'S REALLY
I THINK IMPOSSIBLE TO OVERSTATE
THE IMPACT THAT. THE RABBI HAD
ON THE JEWISH COMMUNITY IN LOS
ANGELES
AS MENTIONED EIGHT. FOUNDED
STEPHEN S. WISE TEMPLE IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR WITH A GROUP
OF THIRTY FIVE OTHER FAMILIES.
AND TODAY IT IS NOW ONE OF THE
LARGEST REFORM CONGREGATIONS IN
THE COUNTRY US SERVING ALMOST
FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS AND
STUDENTS.
IN ADDITION TO CREATING A PLACE
OF WORSHIP RABBIS ALDEN ALSO
TRANSFORM JEWISH EDUCATION IN
LOS ANGELES BY CREATING THE
FIRST REFORM DAY SCHOOL. AT A
TIME WHEN SUCH SCHOOLS WERE
EXTREMELY RARE.
AND ALTHOUGH HE RETIRED IN
NINETEEN NINETY RABBI ZELDIN
REMAINED INVOLVED WITH THE
SYNAGOGUE AND CONGREGATION UNTIL
HIS DEATH.
YOU LEFT A LASTING IMPACT ON THE
LIVES OF ALL WHO KNEW HIM AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WILL
CONTINUE TO BENEFIT EVERY DAY
FROM THE VISION HE HAD. IN HIS
TEACHINGS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN AS MEMORY.
THANK YOU A MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES TO THE DESK TO BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. ALL
REQUESTS TO OBJECT ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS.
REMAINING WILL BE PASS AND
RETAIN. ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED.
SEEN IN HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I AM READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOTIONS MISTER
DALI SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
FEBRUARY FIFTH.
AT ONE PM.
THE JR  FORM HALL IS LIFTED